[Music]
at an early age I mean I didn't know I
was dyslexic at the time that I am
dyslexic and therefore when I went off
to school I found conventional
schoolwork hopeless and you know IQ
tests I would you know turn them upside
down and you know whichever way I turned
them I couldn't make couldn't make sense
of them you know I decided a very young
age that I needed to get out of this
environment and and and you know carved
my own way in life
and unfortunately you know I felt you
know I was strongly anti Vietnam War
that was taking place at the time and
you know I was you know very keen on the
idea of students being able to to have a
voice and you know students to be able
to try to change the what I thought
archaic way that we were taught to do
things so left school at 15 to start a
magazine to try to to change the world
and put the world right
[Music]